hey everyone it's Mike from orls here
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you can join me for today's video where
I'm going to be talking about uh the
orderflow Delta and sort of some of the
problems that I've seen people make with
analyzing the orderflow Delta um but
before we jump in if you enjoy learning
from these videos don't forget to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell so you don't miss any new upload
and if you find today's video helpful be
sure to hit that like button for me and
leave a comment sharing your biggest
takeaway I love hearing your feedback
and often times I do end up making
videos based off of you know user
comments you know basically people
asking me a specific question uh for
further explanation or you know a topic
that they're interested in so you know
your sport really does go a long way in
helping me create more uh content just
like this so if you're getting value
from my channel be sure to uh subscribe
to the channel and let's uh jump into
today's topic all right so Delta right
orderflow Delta now don't confuse
orderflow Delta with options Delta um
what orderflow Delta is it's the net
difference between the aggressive buying
and the aggressive selling um in a
period it could be uh on a bar you know
some people will look at it over um you
know a 30 minute period there's a couple
different ways to look at it but when I
talk about orderflow Delta I'm
specifically talking on about it on a
Barby bar basis and you even have
different uh Deltas that you can look at
you can look at the final Delta when I
talk about Delta that's sort of the
headline number um you know every bar is
going to have it it could be positive or
it could be negative and on
occasion it's more of coincidence I
think um I haven't really found anything
spectacular can't say you know if it
lands on zero people say oh that must
mean something it landed on zero well no
it's just more of a coincidence that you
know the bar just happened to end right
there you know if it's a Time based
chart it just ended its time period and
Delta just happened to be zero cuz it
could have easily been positive or
negative a few contracts but there's Max
Delta which is how strong the Delta was
at one point in the bar its strongest
Point M Delta is the opposite M Delta
will always be negative it's how strong
aggressive selling was in a bar or a
period um then obviously you have
cumulative Delta which is sort of your
running total for Delta during the day
and you know they have Delta divided by
volume as well okay but what I want to
talk about is the actual Delta number
itself okay so you can see here this is
this morning this is this bar
um this red line down here at 48 4527 is
the low of the day and we got a bar with
very strong positive Delta which is what
you know you want to see when you're at
the low of the day it's positive Delta
of 2821 2 uh
821 nice bullish bar right we've got you
know it's one tick off the low you've
got one two three four five buying
imbalances okay which is nice you got a
single print in here four you know it
it's all shaping up to be a nice bullish
bar okay because you know you got the
strong Delta what it's telling you is
that you're at the low of the day and
you got some nice aggressive buying
coming in you know onethird of the bar's
volume is positive Delta the bar traded
8,363 the Delta itself ended up at uh
2821 so again it it's overall strong but
that by
itself while it's a strong indication in
the order flow you still need to have
complimentary order flow what is
complimentary order flow it's follow
through order flow you still need that
buying to continue if you're looking for
this Market to be rallying okay and what
happens in the next bar the next bar is
where you're going to look for
complimentary or confirming or you know
whatever term you want to use for it um
order flow you don't get it it trades
one tick higher than this nice bullish
bar with a bullish order flow it only
trades seven contracts then it trades
back down into the previous bars value
area right that's this greenish area
here that is not a good sign that's not
a healthy sign of a market that is
starting to move away from the low of
the day because if we can't build off of
this bullish bar right if there's not
more buyers stepping in the Market's not
going to go any higher if anything it's
going to do what it did here where it
went sideways eventually it made another
run trying to go higher but in the
meantime it made a new low so just
because you have a nice strong positive
Delta don't immediately jump for joy
thinking hey I got a great trading
opportunity you still need other buyers
to be coming in you need this move to be
sustained going higher at least in the
next bar and again you know I do get
excited when I see something like this
near the low but my excitement is
tempered when the next bar can't even
trade any higher I mean one tick for
seven contracts is not really trading
any higher I'd like to see at least um
two ticks and you know preferably more
to give me some sort of confirmation one
way or the other right but this seven
Lots one tick higher than the high of
the bar that had all the bullish order
flow is not a good sign okay so I'm not
surprised that it went sideways here
okay and again even if I got long even
if I say oh it traded one tick above
okay fine I'm looking to get in the fact
that the next Bar's got a lower high
next Bar's got a lower high I don't need
it to break to a new low to get stopped
out that's my sign that hey you know
what this isn't working out um it's time
to cut that you know cut that loser
now another sort of problem I see with
with Traders making
is getting overly excited with big
negative Deltas at lows of the day now I
I like to see see you know big positive
Deltas at lows of the day but now this
was interesting I'll be honest with you
this is not something you see a lot this
is 827 828 couple minutes before the
cash open you got borrow here with very
strong negative Delta very healthy
volume coming in right ahead of the cash
open which sort of gives me a bit of a
preview that hey you know what today is
probably going to be um or at least you
know the open it's going to go lower um
because you don't usually see this type
of volume you know 7,000 contracts this
is a 1 minute chart
7,425 736 73 76 rather
7,376 but a big negative Delta minus
2100 and then in the next bar you get
that complimentary order flow but
usually again this is coming in right
before the cach open which is not
necessarily a time I'm I'm really
looking to put anything on but this has
the complimentary order for often times
when we're coming into a low you see
that big negative Delta that's what you
expect to see okay I mean now then
you're gauging how much lower you're
going to go would I still take a trade
on a big negative Delta at the low you
know possibly if if I get that
complimentary order flow but personally
I find sort of the best trading
opportunities are going to be that big
positive Delta off the low with the
follow through cuz you know this is what
what kills me sometimes you know people
are like well if you're such a good
Trader why you sharing all your secrets
it's not Secrets right it's there for
it's in the orderflow everyone can see
it as long as they know what to look for
and it's
like okay there's two ways to look at it
and they both have the sort of the same
meaning it's like the the person you
know sometimes I I run into people like
oh I got this method of trading um you I
don't want to tell anybody you know cuz
I'm going to lose my Edge okay well I I
could understand that part of it but at
the same time if nobody else sees what
you're looking at in the
market who else is going to be there to
move the market right if it's such a
super secret
method but nobody else can see it you
know like to get long you know like for
example right say I got the super secret
method here you know they they get short
okay but if nobody else is thinking of
getting short why is the market going to
sell off is it or not cuz once you get
into a trade you got no control over the
market the Market's going to go wherever
it want wants to go okay then at the
same time you know people are like well
you know I can't tell you how I trade
because I'm going to lose my Edge and
again it it's like well your Edge is
probably going to disappear anyway
because you know really what you want to
be looking at are the things that are
obvious that everybody else is looking
at and is going to be moving in that
same direction cuz at the end of the
day if a Market's going to go up up you
need a lot of people to be bullish
Market's not going to go up if everyone
is is bearish right so sometimes you
know that's why people say well you know
if it's so great overflow so great you
know you should just live in Mountain
trade by yourself and you know have all
the money in the world well no you know
I want people to also see what I'm
seeing in the market because you know
I've built a whole trading career and
I'm not talking about a trading career
where I'm just trading from my house in
my pajamas like I'm sitting in right now
you know I worked at JP Morgan for eight
years I worked at Cargill for four years
I've worked at commer bank for several
years Etc so you know a lot of what I
teach is based off of my own personal
experience as an Institutional
Trader so while I say selling into a low
right can the market go lower yeah but
so sometimes you see the market go lower
by a few ticks right yeah I was right I
said the market was going to go lower
it's like yesterday okay let's take a
look at yesterday going into the highs
yesterday there were some bars with nice
big strong positive of Deltas right
here okay
26 23 the Delta 2623 the volume is 5700
almost half of the volume is positive
Delta here new high big positive Delta
2400 the volume for the bar is only
3,900 again the the Delta into the
volume it's 61% that's huge right for
The e- Minis okay can the market go
higher yeah it went higher 1 two three
four five ticks right up here at the
high you got that nice positive Delta
936 it's closing right on its Max
Delta what I'm saying is be careful you
got strong Delta going into the new
highs strong Delta going into new highs
strong Delta at the new highs right new
High new High new high now you could
sort of parse it right put the pieces
together say yes we are making new Highs
but you can see the Delta strong a
little bit weaker
more weaker and then strong selling
comes in this is what I'm talking about
right
where what you want to see is the market
right you want to see the sellers be
coming in at the high buyers going into
the high that's what I'm expecting just
like that what I was showing you earlier
with the
um a minute or two before the 3 minutes
before the cash open with a strong
negative Delta can the market go lower
yeah it can but like here WR Market oh I
got to get long you get long you know 60
it only trades up to 62 and then it
sells off 10 points down to almost
52 here you know here you got the strong
negative Delta now you're starting to
see selling come in the difference
between this high with the negative
Delta and the low that I showed you
earlier with a nice positive Delta now
you're you're trading down right you got
red candle red candle strong volume here
200 even went offered here at 60 you
know then it went sideways then it fell
over but still that's what you like to
see right as compared you know red
candle red candle okay yeah it went
sideways fine fair
enough but
today let's go back to today that one I
was showing you
earlier again you look at this the
little nuances the slight
differences green candle big positive
Delta comes up here trade seven Lots
okay but it's a followed by a red candle
where it trades back inside if this was
a green candle and it's just sort of
hanging around 33 I think it would have
had a much better opportunity to
continue going higher but again I I
still like it I just wish it got some
follow through on
it is what I'm that's all I'm saying
okay and again you know people be like
oh you know here's a look at this red
candle big negative Delta getting
excited Min -400 I got to sell okay goes
one tick lower but then it's followed by
a green candle it got no follow through
the next bar is not
complimentary right if you're looking to
sell and the next bar rallies up that's
that's not good actually goes all the
way up from that low here at uh what is
that 33 and a quar goes all the way back
up to 39 right right here then
eventually yeah it's it went down but
you know are you willing to take five
six points of heat what is that 33 up
the uh what is that 33 and a qu up to 39
yeah almost you know good Five Points of
heat I I don't know maybe I just find it
you know a better opportunity if you're
at the high and you got the big negative
Delta or at a low with big positive
Delta but You' want you know follow
through not it followed with the red bar
again if I was buying it here at 32 and
a quarter this red bar came in even in
here I'd be looking you got to cut it
you just you just got to cut it now
there was another bar here which was
quite interesting um where was it
here it was this bar here
okay this bar wait it's a green candle
again it's got some bullish
information and it's got strong negative
Delta okay so it's telling me at one
point it was minus
1,400 okay so I got you know bullish
value area I've got bullish slingshot
coming in here got imbalance
reversal so early in this bar it's quite
strong selling right cuz obviously
coming down to a new low it's running
into some liquidity in here okay and it
turned
up Max Delta zero see 515 so it actually
went from -400 to just minus 55 15 so it
gained back about a th000 in the
Delta and you got three imbalances in
there as
well it's kind of a hidden move in there
you know and again it's something that
you know potentially you know this
Market could rally off
from however the next bar doesn't even
trade higher you got no complimentary
order flow no follow through order flow
which is not what you're looking for if
you're looking for the market to Rally
off the low now there was another bar in
here also which was uh if I could find
it here
um interesting as well um where where
are you bar losing
track it was also a nice green candle
where the market didn't build off of
anything I can't find it here
now this one when I look at staring at
me right in the face but hit me in the
head it's nice big up green candle right
and again we just came off our low
positive Delta in the next bar okay here
this bar it's got a bullish value area
right it hasn't been retested you point
of control is obviously going
higher thing I don't like it's got 117
Delta instead of you know I'd like it to
be a little bit
higher you a little bit stronger than
117 preferably higher than the previous
bar but nevertheless we get this big p
push up right got nice stacked buying
and balance coming in
here big bar up right that's the type of
bar people get excited people watch
price action this is it the Market's
moving how many times have you looked at
a just a regular simple Candlestick
chart see that big green candle like
this thinking a this is it we're taking
off
however when you look at what's taking
place in the Delta it's big green
candle Delta is only 160 15,000
contractor X trade right
15.7 Delta is only 160 at one point in
this bar it was
989 so it was quite strong in this bar
and it only ended up at 160 that's not a
good sign obviously the next bar goes
inside not a good sign as well inside
again and basically all these bars
inside then you get the big red candle
down with a strong negative Delta this
time minus a th000 but I mean look at
that these are kind of the opposite in
shapes and size big red candle down big
green candle up in this case you got
small Delta it was strong early 9.89
only ended up at60 so it's telling me
that even though this bar is a big
candle up nice big green candle I get
selling coming in late I mean after we
sort of peaked out you know it's one of
those things you know like uh you know
those
carnival games you know you get the
hammer you hit the thing see how far you
could hit
the the the object up to see how strong
you are by looking at the Delta right
imagine Market goes up strong 989 but it
only ends up at 160 here big red candle
down our M Delta's - 1252 we end up at
minus 1011 so it's still quite strong
late in the bar so this one was quite
strong early ended up kind of mixed you
know it was still positive 160 but you
know you'd like it to be closer to the
its Max Delta rather than to the zero
line um here this red candle big red
candle down M Delta how strong negative
Delta was in the bar how strong
aggressive sellers were in the bar and
we're closing near that number minus 10
11 we're only 200 contracts off still
over a th000 so it's quite strong then
the next bar you got that complimentary
order flow right it goes
lower still got negative Delta it's a
red candle green candle followed by a
red candle not a good sign right if
you're looking to get long off of this
big just off of a big green candle some
people like to trade those well I'm just
showing you some of the pitfalls of
doing that so again you know when you
see bars with big
Deltas temper Your
Enthusiasm unless you get some follow
through order flow okay by by what I
mean by follow through order flow is in
the next bar it's a simple thing it's
it's not something that you really got
to pick apart it's simple okay yeah I
got strong selling coming in here is it
continuing if that strong selling is
really manifesting and it continues
you'll see it still in the next
bar here you got strong buying it look
you know it's misleading this big green
bar
up early in the bar strong aggressive
buying but then it tempered
out all right it it's sort of got back
to kind of a a mediocre number in
aggressive buying and then the next bar
went nowhere it stayed
inside so uh that wraps up this video
today on on sort of the pitfalls that
people run into when looking at Delta um
so I hope you found this these tips
helpful for your understanding of order
F Delta let me know what you like me to
discuss next by leaving a comment down
below and again if you enjoyed this
video make sure you subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss any of my
upcoming
uh content so I'll see you guys on the
next video
byebye